[Applaudissements]
on a gagné a dit un peu dubitatif le
candidat de la gauche gustavo petro mais
un triomphe pas encore avec plus de 40%
des voix il arrive largement en tête et
s'attend à devenir le premier président
de la gauche de la colombie mais il
faudra attendre le second tour et ce
sera moins facile qu'on le pensait
car son adversaire sera cet homme
rodolfo hernandez un riche homme
d'affaires de 77 ans ses partisans fête
dans les rues de son fief ou kara manga
dont il a été le maire mais lui il
s'adresse au peuple depuis sa cuisine
aux essarts et muscat you down longtemps
sur un appui mais par hacquard alcan la
corruption comme mon système a évolué à
son programme en finir avec la
corruption comme système de gouvernement
et la politicaillerie s'appelait dans
les médias sociaux ça monte dans les
derniers jours a été fulgurante c'est
lui qui une grippe bettencourt a rejoint
quand elle a mis fin à sa campagne elle
est enthousiaste
jorge fernandes est un type qui va
parler fort qui va dénoncer la
corruption fortement qui va qu'il va pas
faire de proposition invraisemblable
mais il va dire
véritablement ce que les gens pensent
que les choses
comment les choses doivent être prise en
main est ce qu'il faut faire c'est un
bon sens populaire si vous voulez en
même temps c'est quelqu'un d'intelligent
il n'a fait aucune campagne sauf dans
les médias sociaux comme jaillir ball
sauna au brésil où donald trump avec
lesquels on le compare mais en moins
explosif
gustavo petro ne lui fera pas de cadeau
il n'y aura pas justice sociale dit il
s'il ya de la corruption la corruption
ne se combat comme france des dictons
mais on ne combat pas la corruption avec
des phrases en tic toc gustavo petro est
un vieux routier de la politique députés
sénateurs pour fendeur des
narcoparamilitaires maire contesté de
bogota c'est sa deuxième tentative à la
présidence mais il fait peur à beaucoup
de colombiens
colombien là il fait peur à
l'establishment colombien c'est un
leader instruit très intelligent bien
préparé mais les gens n'ont pas à cause
de sa gestion à la mairie de bogota et
aussi parce qu'on le dit autoritaire
allergique à la critique
fico federico gouttière sd sus attend
d'être au deuxième tour il représente la
droite colombienne qui ne voudra jamais
rien savoir d'un gouvernement de gauche
borloo qui a rich gustavo petro ne
convient pas la colombie dans les
combinés en colombie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un danger un danger pour la démocratie
les libertés l'économie nos familles et
nos enfants
les 24 % des voix de fico s'ajouteront
probablement au 28 % de adolfo hernandez
ce qui lui donnerait davantage deuxième
tout
autre première la prochaine vice
présidente sera une femme afro
colombiennes françias marquez pour pète
rose marie line castillo pour adolfo
hernandez la colombie est en train de
faire un pari historique audacieux car
les deux finalistes incarne un énorme
désir de changement mais les colombiens
le 19 juin vont faire un énorme saut
dans l'inconnu après 200 ans
gouvernement conservateur discréditer
jean michel leprince est du canada
bogota